nous les bébés devons faire face à une
crise qui menace est plus simple si je
vous montre ta vie tu veux bien tu
manques dire la lumière voyez-vous les
bébés ne reçoivent plus autant d'amour
qu'avant voici nos plus mortelle ennemis
les chiots non non c'est justement ça le
problème
on est en guerre les choses sont en
train de gagner et les bébés de perdre
c'est pas vrai c'est pas bon
qu'est ce qu'on a fait vous allez
m'aider généraux bien dit mais bon vos
parents travaillent tous pour toutes au
co alors avez-vous appris quelque chose
de oui c'est fait comment génial les
triplés à vont baisser dit non qu'est ce
que vous avez appris au sujet du mot
shoah je messieurs non jimbo les chiots
sont des démons spécialité nôtre c'est à
dire ça dit quoi
c'est ça mon équipe
malabar son cerveau qu'une bande de béni
oui oui une gribouillages exactement
bien mais qui vient ce cookie tout de
suite les cookies c'est pour les
cagnottes n'est pas haut
c'est comme s'il faisait une petite
réunion
[Musique]
la vache c'est trop humiliant
[Applaudissements]